[Música]
el consejo de ministros de españa aprobó
este martes el anteproyecto de una nueva
ley de salud sexual y reproductiva que
incluya nuevas medidas como la supresión
del consentimiento paterno para las
jóvenes de 16 a 18 años que quisieran
abortar o la garantía de la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo en la sanidad
pública además la nueva norma propuesta
por el ejecutivo reconoce también nuevos
derechos reproductivos otros sexuales y
menstruales como el permiso también para
aparte pre parto para a partir de la
semana 39 también las bajas por reglas
incapacidad e incapacitadas pagadas
desde el primer día por la seguridad
social y la gratuidad de la píldora del
día después de los centros de salud
entre otros temas sin embargo no recoge
una demanda ampliamente exigida y es la
rebaja del iva para los productos de
higiene femenina y para ello entonces
quiero dar la bienvenida a nuestra
primera invitada del día ellas noemí
lópez trujillo periodista de neutral
especializada en feminismo salud y
derechos reproductivos gracias por estar
con noemí en directo américa de france
24 y por supuesto también aquí en esta
mesa de trabajo nos acompaña nuestra
periodista de nuestro programa más
romeros sala especializada en salud
además mujer y español hablando de esta
ley en españa mar hola raúl muy buenos
días y también muy buenos días a noemí
podemos empezar con las preguntas
primero que todo una pregunta muy
general no queríamos saber qué
implicaciones para los derechos de las
mujeres de las personas gestantes y
personas me entró antes tiene esta ley
bueno pues tiene muchas implicaciones
pero es verdad que es importante
recordar que todavía es digamos un
planteamiento legislativo que tiene que
pasar toda la fase parlamentaria todo el
trámite parlamentario entonces todavía
no hay aprobado nada como tal pero es
verdad que introduce bastantes cambios
que se venían demandando porque aunque
en 2010 en españa se aprobó una ley que
era en el papel muy garantista y bueno
fue muy avanzada en europa en ese
momento es verdad que se han venido
detectando
problemas en la implementación por
ejemplo desigualdades territoriales por
ejemplo que muchas mujeres o hombres
trans o personas no binarias no pueden
acceder a la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo con garantías porque se tienen
que desplazar porque es una prestación
sanitaria que digamos se ha desarrollado
y sufragada por el estado pero se ha
desarrollado en clínicas privadas y no
en todos los territorios hay estas
clínicas privadas entonces los de los
desplazamientos son muy habituales hay
provincias que directamente ya no
notifican abortos y luego por ejemplo
otro problema es que la sanidad privada
dijéramos absorbido no estas clínicas
privadas han absorbido toda esta demanda
y no es solamente que sean privadas sino
que son entornos en su mayoría extra
hospitalarios con el riesgo que eso
puede conllevar sobre todo cuando se
practican abortos terapéuticos es decir
a partir de la semana 15 y luego pues
bueno hay reivindicaciones no como todo
lo que hablábamos de la salud menstrual
no todo lo que tiene que ver con
procesos reproductivos como por ejemplo
pues que puedas tener una baja después
de una interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo o que puedas tener por ejemplo
una baja por incapacidad temporal porque
tienes un dolor menstrual que te
incapacita y que está asociado a una
patología y también se ha introducido
esta baja que no se descuenta del
permiso de maternidad en la semana 39
del embarazo que bueno es verdad que la
reclamación siempre ha sido que fuese a
partir de la semana 36 37 como muy tarde
porque la semana 39 pues muchas mujeres
ya han dado a luz no pero bueno estas
son algunas de las novedades que serían
muy importantes y finalmente este
proyecto legislativo se aprueba
así es mi novedad es que vamos a ir
desgranando pero antes de desgranar
digamos todo este anteproyecto ley bien
extensa vamos a tratar de por supuesto
resumirlo aquí en directo américa en
este espacio
quisiera preguntarle cómo están las
cosas dentro del congreso es decir tiene
posibilidades de que este proyecto de
ley se convierta ya en una ley
sancionada
yo creo que si tiene posibilidades
además se va a tramitar por la vía de
urgencia es verdad que tienen que llegar
pues todos los documentos de los órganos
consultivos yo creo que sí que tiene
posibilidades porque
seguramente con enmiendas porque es
verdad que
incluye cosas que no se pueden entender
dentro del marco de la salud
reproductiva pero que son muy matizable
que igual meterlas en una reforma de ley
orgánica es complicado hablo por ejemplo
de la gestación por sustitución entonces
igual que han dejado fuera finalmente lo
del iva para poder llegar a consensos
parlamentarios
según las declaraciones de la ministra
de igualdad se prevee meterlo en
los presupuestos generales del estado
esa rebaja del iva entonces yo creo que
sí que hay creo que sí hay muchas
posibilidades de que salga adelante pero
por supuesto con cambios por eso tenemos
que ir un poco como hablando en
condicional porque de lo que se propone
a lo que finalmente salga pues igual a
un 30 por ciento se queda por el camino
noemí queríamos hablar de uno de los
temas que más titulares se ha ganado
alrededor de esta reforma de ley que es
el tema de las bajas por reglas
dolorosas sabemos que hay mucho estigma
alrededor de este tema queríamos
preguntarte primero pues a cuántas
mujeres podría afectar realmente no que
sabemos de que cifras tenemos alrededor
de ésta y dolencias y segundo si
realmente es real o podría ser verdad
que hubieran entonces una discriminación
en los lugares de trabajo por ejemplo a
la hora de nuevas contrataciones
el número aproximado es muy difícil
porque ni siquiera hay como un registro
a día de hoy en españa tú te puedes
[__] una baja porque tengas un dolor
menstrual o sea eso es eso es cierto es
verdad que sería una baja como todas las
bajas por enfermedad común que no sería
remunerada sano sería retribuida perdón
no sería retribuida desde el primer día
sino a partir del cuarto día a coste de
la empresa luego ya pasaría a ser
costeada por la seguridad social
entonces tú puedes hacerlo pero es
verdad que es muy complicado en tanto
que tienes que conseguir cita presencial
para que el profesional sanitario te
evalúe ese mismo día antes tienes que
conseguir cita en un momento en el que
hay una saturación sanitaria importante
en un contexto además en el que las
mujeres y personas que menstrúan nos
hemos acostumbrado a que esto es un tabú
y no le demos importancia ya que tomemos
fármacos entonces hay una cosa
importante también y es que previendo
que una parte importante de la población
femenina
tiene estos dolores
implicaría que si nos
acogemos a estas bajas por enfermedad
común estaríamos perdiendo dinero cada
mes eso supondría también una
discriminación por sexo género en el
ámbito laboral entonces un poco lo que
viene introducir esta norma es previendo
que esto le pasa a más mujeres de las
que nos gustaría y que evidentemente
esto hay que no vale sólo con la baja
sino que se tiene que investigar que la
medicina tiene que digamos
neutralizar ese sesgo de género que
tiene investigar porque tantas mujeres
tienen dolores menstruales muchas veces
incapacitantes teniendo en cuenta eso
esto lo que vino digamos es un poco a
neutralizar ese sesgo o esa
discriminación que se podría producir en
el ámbito laboral dado que pues una
inmensa mayoría de personas
que menstrúan pues tienen dolores
menstruales una parte incapacitante si
portillo se perdería un salario cada mes
9 y también yo le quiero preguntar sobre
el aborto porque sí es verdad que es
legal en españa también como hay muchas
trabas a la hora de aplicarlas en qué
cambiaría digamos esta ley cómo hacer
para que para que tenga regularidad en
ese territorio hablaba hablabas también
al principio de esa diferencia que hay
una persona que vive en un pueblo a lo
mejor dentro del territorio español en
persona que vive en la ciudad y esas
dificultades mar también lo hablamos que
pues digamos que eso es un problema que
sufre todo todo el mundo digamos también
aquí en colombia en los países donde el
aborto digamos no está penalizado
también es difícil acceder a varias
personas que quisieran tener ese derecho
que no viven en una silla principal por
supuesto también la importancia de que
sea en la pública no porque esta
diferenciación en esta ley no m
bueno a ver es la ley actual dice que
debería realizarse preferentemente en la
pública sobre todo cuando son abortos a
partir de la semana 15 el problema es
que la estructura que teníamos
con la anterior legislación sobre el
aborto había hecho que todo lo absorbía
sel a la privada entonces cuando se
implementa esta ley con muchas críticas
además hace 12 años pues eso con muchas
críticas y mucha dificultad básicamente
un poco lo que se hace es expulsarlo de
la pública un poco como de bueno estamos
dando esta prestación pero lo sacamos de
la pública para que no haya tantos
problemas esto lo que ha provocado entre
muchas cosas por ejemplo pues los
problemas asociados a que tengas que
desplazarte
pagando tú el coste la incomodidad que
supone
las barreras que supone para muchas
personas también ha supuesto que como
son clínicas localizables las que
practican los abortos muchas los
acosadores no todos estos grupos
antiaborto están en esas puertas en las
puertas de esas clínicas si tú lo tienes
implementado la pública nadie sabe para
qué entras a un centro sanitario
entonces lo que propone la propuesta de
ley del gobierno es que la pública
implementando tanto el método quirúrgico
como el farmacológico pues de alguna
manera siempre pueda asegurar que haya
al menos uno o varios profesionales
sanitarios para que se todas las mujeres
puedan acceder a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo